[Ethan] Welcome back everybody to the H3 podcast live on twitch.tv/H3H3productions
Today we have a very special impromptu episode. I'll tell you what, we've been thinking about doing the show twice per week
We're thinking about bringing a Tuesday episode to you guys, where we have a top of the week where we've discussed
What's going on in the world, have some laughs, have some goofs, just me and Hila
hanging out
Maybe sometimes some some people come and hang with us but on Friday. We have the
Interviews and our traditional stuff there, but I think it would be bring a good balance to have like our us time
and
You know that all of us time
[Hila]: It's like the top of the month
But Top of the Week. [Ethan]: Yeah, Top of the Month we cram everything into one episode ends up being like three-hour marathon
We could do that every week be more current have some laughs along the way, every week
So here's basically our pilot
Attempt to do that, and I'm thinking about cutting it down making about like an hour-long each episode something about that about that length
So yeah, that's what we're thinking
so let's give it a shot and
A quick, quick, thank you
We have no sponsors today, so our real and only sponsors, as it has always been, is the wonderful people...
on Twitch prime and our subscribers on Twitch, you guys are my heart and soul, okay?
And when I lay in bed at night with Hila. I'm not thinking about her. I'm thinking about you guys. I'm saying she's cool
I like her but my twitch prime subs. That's who I'm freaking.
[Hila]: I disapprove of that message.
[Ethan]: Hila too she act like she's - I know you think about our twitch prime subs, don't act like that's not your (...)
[Hila] Yeah I'm dreaming of those emoticons, when I go to sleep.
[Ethan] More emoticons...
So anyway, thank you, everybody who supports the show let's get into it...
(cough?) A couple things on my chest, I want to get off first and foremost before we get into the memes.
[Hila]: Mm-Hmm
[Ethan]: I'm back on Fupa Loss. [Hila]: Right
You know I did was do it really good. I was up to 205...
[Hila]: When you started...[Ethan] When I was at my fattest. [Hila]: Yeah. [Ethan]:I was a Monster...
[Hila]: You did really good you got sick...lost the progress. [Ethan]: Yeah, that's the killer hopefully I got to stay healthy
But I was so fat at the onset like I don't know if I talked about this
But I was so.. I was such a monster man like I would lean over to tie my shoes and I would couldn't breathe
Like that's not a joke like it was a large
It was big shh, you know I stopped wearing tennis shoes
only sneakers only Vans
[Hila]: Stop wearing tenn.. what? [Ethan]: I couldn't tie, I couldn't tie the lace I was like this is not
How animals are meant to live on this Earth?
[Hila]: Especially not in their thirties
[Ethan]: Well... [Hila]: That's like someone in their 70s.
[Ethan]: Yeah.
Man, they're in deep trouble. Nobody nobody. [Hila]: Nobody. [Ethan]: Age, age aside
You shouldn't suffocate to lean down to your foot
And I actually felt my ribs being pushed out of my body
I'm like this fat this fuckin disgusting
food I'm eating every day is
terraforming my body
The ribs are being displaced by the fat, so I had this moment of realization
I'm like all right dude time to time to get on that fupa loss, so I lost 10 pounds
I don't know maybe I lost like 15 pounds. [Hila]: Yeah, maybe 15.
[Ethan]: *Coughing out his lungs*
and uh
and
Then I got sick like Hila said, and I was like eh fuck it and I was like I fuck my life
[Hila]: Well when you're sick, you can't exercise, and then you start also eating whatever because you don't feel well
[Ethan]: Yeah, you need comfort. [Hila]: Yeah you need that comfort food. [Ethan] You're vulnerable.
[Hila] And then it's so hard to get back to it so... [Ethan] Right, and then eventually you lose your rhythm
And you're like eh fuck, fuck my life.
This cheeseburger is more important than being me living over the age of 50 is that strange. I'm fully a food addict
Like it's straight. You people are like. Oh, you're addicted the hair when you're addicted to meth alcohol these problems
I'm a food addict and I'm kicking that addiction. [Hila]: Yeah. [Ethan] When I could when I...
When my ribs are being pushed out of my body, and I'm feel it and I'll still go eat a cheeseburger and French fries
That's an addiction. That's sick
[Hila] When you start to get uncomfortable in your own body...[Ethan]: Right. [Hila]: It's like maybe do something about that? [Ethan]: Yeah, take it take your fate into your own hands.
It's uncomfortable. It's disgusting and it's unhealthy.
[Hila]: But it's hard to make that change. I mean I see when you're really trying, and I see how hard it is
To do that way, it's like the most annoying thing but on one hand it's like
It's good to acknowledge it as an addiction
It should give you some more sympathy for people who suffer from being like a you know a fat fucking monster
Right to put it sensitively
It's effective or not more. I will have that much like oh fucking eejit whale difference and fighting to get back to the ocean
But it's good to think about it as an addiction right you don't say yeah, dammit
Stop just stop doing heroin you're you know. I mean you got to think about complicated and complication
Yeah complicated
So anyway, I've been doing good. I've been exercising hard man. I've been hitting that that elliptical
Mm-Hmm. I've been dieting I go to bed starving I
Don't know if that's record, but that's how you do it
But I I don't know I need to see results quick otherwise I get discouraged
So I'll starve myself. I called the concentration Camp diet
Just like it is the start of my son to write a book. I don't know just carve my book will be banned in America
Fat so the fat cow monsters of America. Maybe what a concentration camp diet
That'll be the title everyone's Gonna love it
Anyway, I woke up this morning super hungry because I hit the gym last night by that I mean the elliptical machine
And I was starving because I went to bed hungry, and we've got a Starbucks
And I'm always looking for like a healthy alternative for the food and they have this one item called the I
Always fucking crack up when I say I can't take people seriously
It's called the feta cheese egg white white sliced tortilla wrap
like a whole run-on sentence
then egg white spinach fettuccine
We trapped and it's like you have to say like whimsically and they're like all right sir
And if you if you try to like not say the full thing they always like what yeah, what say it, so?
This is really shame you
Say it
Like with the coffee sighs I refuse to say their names
So every time like I want a small coffee, so they're like. Oh, you wonder
The recipe it is socially needed
that's what that
Okay, I know this is like this has been running to the ground about Starbucks, but seriously what the fuck
small a large
Medium and I don't I don't play by the rules. I'm a rebel okay. I?
might get the feta egg white spinach Tortellini
But I refuse to say fucking tall or grande. I want a medium coffee. You know what I mean don't make me say
Anyway, I get this diet food
Back it's just such a con this health food
Didn't they give you this egg white and it's like oozing with like butter and cheese, and they're like. Oh, there's spinach in it
That's healthy, and it's like little flakes of spinach. That was sauteed in butter
You know and I'm eating this more eating this on the way over and I'm like
She's the one I want him
You ever eat a meal, and you're like. I would be better off not having put this in my body
Yes, a lot. I think that a lot. I would my body would be healthier
I would be healthier in life if I just straight-up didn't eat this meal
So I felt about it a little bit
All right, and pretty good
I'm I'm a fan of eating at home. So for me almost every time I get out it's how I feel
Say that again. I just I like eating at home like you just can't compare that to food you get outside
Yeah, I know what's in there? You got fresh fresh vegetables. You know what yo you know when you eat out? It's like
I don't know what?
How I got this food
And what happened in the product and some chef who was back there who doing wiped his fucking hands if ya shit his finger broke
Through the baby wipe and he's like that or like when you're at home you have this thing
You have like this mix of lettuce and stuff and it's got a date on it
And if it's one day pass, we like to throw it out. I freak out throw it
I don't know if they do it in the restaurant. Yeah, you may be eating like a
Two-week-old yeah, well probably are when you get a head of lettuce
And you washing the little bugs and grime out do they do that. They're busy people probably not
So yeah, I don't like eating out either
And so that you know that's my rant for the morning pretty much cover everything on the Agenda. They're
Moving on to the next story here
Top story you guys probably saw this it was a really special mean
This was circulating on Twitter
Everywhere the Joey salads is a fucking nazi memes. Oh good
Thank God, okay
So on Twitter somebody originally tweeted out something like to those of you who say trump supporters aren't nazis look at this picture
I'm in fucking erase windows. I hate windows so much bill gates. You make it cure Malaria, but you'll never make me
not want to flip and Kick a
wall
anyway
So somebody tweets out, you know
To people who say not all trump supporters are not to look at this picture, and it's Joey salad corn anachronism
Oh for fuck sake Joey of course
And then everybody starts retweeting this and it starts picking it up this makes your choice colleges at the Nazi
What does that guy should say obama called me Klinger Hillary calls me up horrible Terrorist call me infidel trump calls me
American
That's a little dramatic dude, but regardless you have joey cells standing next to the swats gonna sleeve. You seem very reasonable
So this is from a prank from like months ago
And the media picks it up, and everyone's like oh shit. That's joey south we don't really look into it obviously
Who looks at anything these days except me?
So people thought he was that
They're at their island Charlotte's right last week
So you guys probably follow this whole thing in Charlottesville where there was like a white supremacist who freaking ran over people I?
mean if you're if you have to be living under a rock not to have heard about that I
Really nothing to add to that. It hasn't even said bye everybody, but everybody thought Joey salads was there
And I'm not see Swasey and everyone's like what the fuck Joey - territory
De NasI and so obviously you know he's not a nazi. He's just a salad head I know that
Looks you guys know that my no
And it's from a prank for a months ago
Let me watch it. I got it here. Yeah. What was the prank about? Yes?
So he prank was about not see a trump Rally social experiment our trump supporters nazis
Here's a here's a brief excerpt from that video
Reaching out to we're enough to welcome to be Romeo over there on that side
Where we don't see it right it was a dilemma. Oh shit
I'm getting used to this group Format. I don't say
There you go
We should get you a mouse. Yeah, mouse would be helpful. So here it is people over there on that side. They've been telling us
Reaching out to we renounced you you're welcome to be here
We can't stop you, but I don't know why you're doing this but it's not a cosplayer
We do not agree with bridge out there. I thought I thought we were nazis said that people are their class not
the sword
Truck let's work. Let's do see that you have ready. I don't think your exact, but the left a name there
I thought we were the Nanshan says that they all said no. We're literally killing Mr.. Butcher, but they say all
Right well that was a good job you get I got a whole new context after the eyes wake of it
What do you mean?
Well, I just if you went like that to the Raleigh. Oh that would be a really bad timing to do that experiment
Yeah, there a chance. They'd be like let's go do it come on. Here's your shield
Here's your shield is ours. I think here's your ticket George do it can you imagine Joey like fish out of water like?
Anyway, it turns out. It actually had like a
relatively
Nice message. Yeah, he went out there, and he's a he's an idiot guys was he real about it
You know we love him to death to tell that he goes out there, and he's like hey
We're nazis right heil hitler and they're like no dude. What the fuck's wrong with you
Wrong event wrong in here at the wrong event good
Okay, so actually a relatively heartwarming
show of
rebuking him and the Nazis, they're
Not that I think that
Trump supporters are Nazis was just it was a nice see
But on the other hand you kind of have to accept that when you go out into the world just as a nazi
Joey Kinda hard to explain. I should ask Pewdiepie
It's tough to get away with those jokes all right
But now there's just been a huge media blitz about how joey cells is the nazi units everywhere
yeah is
Kind of like shouldn't joke around with this stuff. I guess especially after all these things happening lately
This was before I know but now it's really not always loved it. Yeah, so when we shout out to our
Favorites a little not want appreciate you
Dead Air
next up
Jake Paul Drops the Mic literally
Jay Paul hosted and performed at the teen choice award. That's kind of shocking to me
It's hard to imagine a world where Jake Paul is actually
Below I mean I know he is but the disconnect that big teen choice awards on
Nickelodeon Would I
Know he won two awards. He was nominated for he hosted the dang thing he performed. I mean I was just
those pins I
Don't know a teen choice award what how far up the teen are we going because I feel like there it got about 15
Yeah, I think our fans are like 12 should be the adolescence awards I
guess it all falls under the same thing probably
Should be the dependents awards
Sherwood should be the mom bring me a juice box or worse
Anyway, Jake Paul drops the mic literally?
Hey guys, let it go, but I am forgetting let me drag this over actually you guys can see it. It's every day, bro
Oh, thank you. Dan. It's everyday go it's everyday
So that's it
this
motorbike
I like that jump that is good a little leap really went for it. Also. I like that he word everyone
He made it everyone else wear red, and he's in blue. I guess it's his home. He's the star
the star
Users it. He is the ceo of 10 team 10
Just slick don't get it twisted. Don't get it twisted
I love that when he dropped the mic the sound didn't change at all
How's that work some kind of Black Magic?
By the way, I guess I can announce this now because it's pretty official at this point, but this Friday guess who's our guest
every day my dogs
We've got a white a fucking episode planned for this Friday. You will not want to miss Jake Paul is coming in
And are you sure you want to miss tell them the surprise?
Huh?
Yeah, why not okay? And a KtLa reporter?
That you know broke this story about Jake Paul is coming in as well
It's going to be a blockbuster my friends. I'm excited and
I think it's gonna be I think it's going to be a fascinating. I think we need up there. Yeah your load
We found one or more settings on your battery
That will help improve your life. I plugged it. I don't care about the battery. I don't care about update
I don't care but one on it off a windows everyday by the way every day tomorrow, right?
Fuck I didn't know bill Gates would love Jake Multiband updates
Getting killed out there. I'm getting fucking hammered
vin diesel
Yeah, a fucking dead
and
that voice is
Something on her alright, so ben. This is kind of a old clip, but I haven't seen before it's becoming my favorite clip get ready
Where's my mouth Vin diesel?
Professes love for a brazilian Youtuber during an interview get a load of this shit man
to the first one
That can't be his real voice. That's the first one me. Thank you to blame that is it up?
Guy so beautiful my right eye wrong look
How am I supposed to do is and if you look at this woman? Tell me she's so beautiful go mad
And sing the better price. How's that in real life? There's no way?
Hey, not even speak in English. He's just like low rumbling. Why have you never seen a woman?
He's never seen a woman before it
Think you play it just got here from Mars, but never seen a scene on the farm
I'm too black
Talk to me, baby
so this book values within
God, what God?
on account of you
Thank you, you probably just motorboats them. He does probably as a micropenis and it gets women off. He goes down on them goes
Hey guys good. God and he
Kind of told me was Gonna be like
And the last thing I wanted I saw a new speaking
I am groot in so many languages, but I don't know if you ever send it in portuguese
So I brought you
What you think about help? They're so good who's what do you think about a Delta?
I'm a fan of the sleeveless shirts in all kinds. I know you're a big fan. Well, you're the fashion police healer
You're the guru what do you let me give them a critique your joan rivers on the red carpet
What do you say to the guy?
It's just so it's so Madhouse
Wow
It's just wow
It's such a parkour guy
cut off plaid
aviator glasses
But can you keep playing it sounds like I?
Can't get another fitted to go so gooch
Can you believe that?
Tiffany was David guys I
Don't know what this thing is look at her. What do you want? It's so crazy?
Do you think you smashed it is like? What's wrong. I don't know. What is wrong
You're doing everybody jumping over the couches and drop the cameras to come try to fucking put their dick on this girl
It's crazy. I've never seen anything like yeah, I've never seen anything like it I
Don't think he has to try that hard either
He's a movie star, and I mean his clothing is on point,  his voice is on point
I'm getting Rock-hard just from the vibrations of the bass in the room is making my dick grow
She's so fucking beautiful. It's like you can't even do it
Get away
Very wrong oh my God someone save you with the beautiful world
beautiful world
when this turn the beautiful world
Open your eyes yes looking at us and we just join in a beautiful world I
Think she's our girl. Oh yeah as soon as he got out of a shooter and
As soon as he got up, it's like. Oh shit stay where you are moving
Do you think he fucked her?
She ran. She look creep out of my hand and I wait. Here's part 2
There's a sequel to this ohs it's just ot Mp
Harris Backstage
She does seem weirded out by it yeah
We got drugs. I mean it. I mean we almost changed. I don't know
I love what he's having I want to enter beautiful world. Are you sure who is big no?
I don't know actually I'm not sure why it's a beautiful world. He put on a camera
Nice, little changes what what was that?
Their intro now show to give a she's a fuckin
So anyway, I identified that was an interesting one. This is crazy
I've seen vin diesel in interviews, and I liked him really I haven't that's my first clue
He plays like dungeons & Dragons and shit. He's like a nerd
So it's just hiring something here, maybe
Something is wrong. Well. I mean are I mean did you not see her?
Love is a drug. They say you
Sometimes I go to her in my office. I'm patent owner all right. Thank you for that down
What else we got on Deck here my friends Mike tyson in an interview?
This is an interesting one because it
Curious what your your take us on this one having seen this yeah this one's good. This is a good video
So Mike yeah, it's called Mike tyson swears on TV, but that's really not even the point of the video
Welcome back many of you probably know that Mike tyson come I do which happiness in a pound he met up with Mayor Rob Ford
He joins us right now with this promoter Alex Henry joining us both of you
And I'll go with yourself many are wondering how does that happen this meeting was in there. I'm going to inside clothing again. I
Know the end of the day is Mayor of the city Mike tyson is here to promote the first ever
performance in Canada and
When I had sugar Ray leonard come to montreal the Mantra when the mayor's office, we're here to have it. We both
Community in the history of Ronald with a man and bigger Denotes those city you can select a name
but in the city of Amman conceived again and in our
Community and Dynamic character arrested you he read up on any server call nigeria one my watched on television
but in m using a big big instinct
And what some of your critics would say yelled is a race for Mayor?
We know you're a convicted rapist this can hurt it campaign how would you respond to that? Hey?
how does it the United you know means and
How animal commandeer you know because we can tell?
That off you call. What happen Mike Tyson's if a convicted rapist right and
That happened a long time ago, and it was crowded in controversy. It was his girlfriend
Who accused him of right? And you know it's he went to prison for it ended his career
Mm-Hmm, you know nobody want it's very controversial t
So anyway this guy's like your convicted rapist. What do you say to the people who say it?
So it doesn't it's not a good look for him
For the mayor to be hanging out with you Mmm-hmm that mike fucking loses it and I think understandably
It's kind of a fuckin like curveball right begs would come in Toronto having a good time
So you're a convicted rapist, and this is after you spend time
Oh, this is for never like fifteen years. Yeah, okay. Nobody nobody
You know please that shit doesn't come up really but anyway
It's on live television and he's out here trying to promote his live show. They're on tour there
I don't know. It's kind of I don't know
Here's I'll continue. Thank you. This ue- Stop and I
Found Mittman I'm missing here
Nothing to do about it
Time we talked about Georges seurat. Oh
it is remoter tease my great happiness my life and going to the time yes, but it like napkins my
Emotion we should be open to make that was really a piece of shit you
Are doing too much TV on can't you what are you there? - only you are like we are. I think we are
We're gonna draw it's the real paralyzed easier to see your show the tells it about
you know
It's people kind of hard to pressure my dad today our pre-production one can be friends like I'm calm be calm
I and we're really really from yeah
It's like is a human being what you brought it up
And now you want him to just move on and go back to like all smiley mode it's yeah, a little hard no
That's not that question
It's not the right set
It's not the right type of player, but I love I mean look. I don't know for my crate. I don't know
you know I have no patience for
Rapist obviously, but the mic one was pretty controversial. It's a time is a time. I mean like someone. I don't know
It's kind of tricky you hear, but anyway Mike is such character. Yeah
Yes, we're looking at me on the gorillas over it's over tonight
We're going to be looking for our last right it is nerve-racking beauty some like this. There's a more nervous for you box
It's not no rhymes medias talking to a reputation. Oh
Look at it. French sling are you?
I love it. Mike is a words in it good for him. I
Love Mike tyson for the firm. We're all people like if you're gonna ask him a mensch it still with the query
I think it's better to not be like oh well
My shooting tonight is going to be great. I'm more nervous boxing than performing and you just called me a rapist
If anything it's more humanizing of Mike because it shows that wasn't just something I didn't already forgot about it
Doesn't matter if he did it or not, but obviously it was the dark thing in his life
Yeah, and you don't just bring it up playback me Mike tyson is one of the most interesting
People really jude has been through so much he had such a rough upbringing was the champion by like 19
went to prison for rape
controversy surrounded in controversy
Came out his career was over and then his daughter
Fucking had a freak death
Did you know that until you told his daughter like fell out of a window or so or at some freak?
No, it wasn't even that. It was like totally outside of his control
Dan can you look that? I'll tell you
Anyway, and here she died in a tragic accidents on a treadmill
mom, that's why a
Hanging accident involving a treadmill like something that never foresee her prevent her daughter dies like and that fucks like I don't know man
He's an interesting guy dude. I love the way he talks. Yes faster. It is fascinating and I like
One of my favorite quotes of all time
He's talking shit to this boxer on live on Live TV. And he says to the guy
I'm gonna fuck you till you love me fag
Yeah, I
Mean that's just so beautifully stated as an insult
I can't think of anything better just at the top of your head. I mean, it's just
It's beautiful. So anyway this was a good one dude scares the wrong lady
This one's a little old triggering these people kind of pissed me off
Let's have a look
Alright, so you know. Thanks this guy looks like a class act already
He'll at Miller high life hat with that ain't it so bent
The Deeper the bend the more the inbred is what they say
Looks like he's missing a couple teeth
This lady is dying. She's horrified
His girlfriend is taking the ship way too lightly you gonna show her face again
Can you throw?
my God
Look okay. She's hyperventilating
Hello. He's like oh my God. I'm so sorry
Let me go put this on YouTube
And not blur your face. I'm so sorry
Great. There's a world out there my friends with people with bent hats hats bent way more than is reasonable
scaring people in Batten Hallways
Filming them I'm telling you me on the world that there's crazy. It's crazy
Back me up on that you
Yep, thanks
When you got support like that let me tell ya the world is my oyster this show is on
tappable
What else we got here?
Got some other stories
Disney is pulling out all of its content from Netflix Hulu Amazon every streaming platform Disney's pulling out
you know just like
My Dad wishes he did
bad jokes
Kind of it's still a little too sexual for a joke, but I see your point is kind of they're in the same thing
Yeah, early bad. Yeah, early dad Joke free Fatherhood
So they're pulling out and my first thought was like whoa
Good luck idiots you know
But Disney Owns
But wait, they're pulling out because the other starting their own streaming platform, right?
Yeah, they're starting their own streaming platform and give me a fucking break
How many of these companies are so entitled to our ten dollars per month? I'm not I can you break
I can't even count all them
Memberships we have four stop playing like a thousand dollars a month and like random ten ten member dollar membership fees yeah every time
And it's getting to the point where it's kind of defeating the whole purpose
so
you have these streaming flat platforms to combat piracy and
cable cable television which nobody our age has
super expenses like $120 a month for like
Got church
Sports at home shopping and like three channels you actually watch
You're actually watching commercials
with sports
commercials with yeah
Cable doesn't make sense to me as a product anymore you paid way more money $120 a month
And then they it's half of it is like super intense commercials yeah, so then you have these streaming platforms. They're blowing up
They're competing with cable. I'm paying Netflix hulu Amazon between those three. I'm paying like 30 dollars a month, but it just starts they're
paying like show time
To watch yeah, you know there's there's all kinds until I can ollie okay show time. I play Playstation yeah and your crunchyroll
I hey everybody
Way, I shouldn't take much role. I don't I'm not a weeaboo
I'm kidding. I love country don't be ashamed. I'm kidding
Anyway, so now it's coming to the point where all these companies think that. They're worth fucking that all of our money
It's becoming so fragmented to bread to youtube right like we have so many. I'm just trying to check right now
Yeah, you pay itunes right. I know it's crazy. It's getting to the point where we might as well. Just get cable
Although a different way yeah, but it's becoming so fragmented all these companies being like oh my shits fucking worth every
Fuck the consumer. I'm Disney
We make it we make skids content, but we're run by sociopaths. I'm Disney
It's becoming so fragmented that it's like it's defeating the purpose
Yeah
Anyway, so I'm like. Oh fuck off Disney. I'm not buying your crap
I'm still not buying the crap button just to give you an idea of how much property they actually oh, they own pixar
everything Pixar's ever made lucasfilm
Star Wars
Marvel everything Marvel, Abc
What you know all those and all those late night shows you watch even those might be owned by Disney
Oh shit, because they own ABc they own an A&E Network history channel lifetime blaze crime
And I'm all into the crime and investigation
Network Espn a lot of people care about that touchstone pictures
There's way more than that. Oh and aaa. They had that good scientology
serious I
Just don't see it though cuz it's like it's mostly kids content Disney
I feel like but then you have a lot of other serious films, and it's just it's weird who's it for yeah
It's Gonna be a weird collection of stuff. Just fuck off
Don't they have enough money. Yes in short yes, but they do have enough money
Star Wars made like 10 Trillion dollars in it in its first day
No, but it did make like a billion dollars in its opening weekend like you're fine
Disney did the Disney executives are sociopaths? I'm not kidding herbalife you guys know about this company. It's like this giant like a
pyramid Scheme Scheme company, and so covered in the
disguise of being with the name of that documentary
And I'll remember
but
They say they have products for like betting on 0 yeah
They have this health product
apparently they sell like shakes and that kind of stuff, but it's all just a skin well, it's
Well, it's a pyramid scheme
So essentially it's this veil and but it's not even about selling the products right that's what makes a good pyramid scheme
Yeah, the product isn't actually the product the product is the affiliation where you have to go recruit people to sell under you
You know sue pyramid Scheme and so basically this company herbalife was like
You know a little bit of an underground pyramid scheme and then like ten years ago this guy who?
Rose to the ranks of one of the head directors of Disney
got hired by herbalife to take over and this guy turns it into like this worldwide scheme and
I seen this guy in this documentary betting 2-0 is really interesting I recommended a liar and I'm looking at this guy dude and
Man ie could just ease as a sociopath that guy would put poison and baby food and go to bed at night and sleep like
an angel it probably does
It's wild this is the kind of guy who would give your fucking nana tumble down the stairs and say goodnight
to his children because some gimmick is I mean I'm telling anyway that's neither here nor there to be honest, but
The point is I don't like Disney. I don't trust them and if you guys are looking for your next spokesman. I'm available
You can contact me. I love her making content and set us up anytime Disney
Actually everyone. I know who's worked for Disney. Which I have some friends who have they all hire right now not fired
But they all unanimously hate it. They're like. They're their slave drivers just I've you got to love the irony of this daisy
Disney work for us work your work, your bones to the dust anyway
Streaming services man not there's nothing we can't we don't deserve anything. Good is
Everything good in this world Gets destroyed
eventually the internet is being fucked over by
Comcast
Search Comcast on Google a Nazi, Swastika comes up
Streaming services by Disney give me a fuck your bright leave something for me
The distribution of wealth in this country is already fucked your truck if you want to not see your head on a freaking
Guillotine like the French revolution leave our streaming platforms alone, it's all we have
I'm to foster the people. Can you making are you starting a revolution yeah? I?
Might be Disney listen to my call
This is not a threat for violence. It's just a joke and if you are like a first spokesman, I'ma go anyway
What's up, next oh?
Man this story is awesome
Thank you
Elon Musk Elon musk. I love this guy man Elon musk
I would probably if he was like yo doug. Here's my dick. I need you I knew it
I said we going before you said I wasn't you thought I was gonna say so
He wants me to shine it and manicure it
Look, I need you to
Manscape my genitals. I'm not doing Joe I
don't require Payment I
Love the guy some people hate him. I don't know why
He's like the real-life Tony stark all right. It really is I mean come on the guy's incredible
He's he's pioneered
commercial space travel
Opens the doors for so many things that guy has made driving electric vehicles cool
Clicking point where he made a profit and now he's making them
Consumable the Model 3 mark my words in 2 or 3 years when that shit is goes into mass production
You're going to see that all across the country
People say people always say oh, oh well electric vehicles are just as wasteful as gas oh
I've got a fucking stick in my ass, and I have to complain and be sour and contraband contrary about everything not true solarcity
Lungs even got that I'm getting to the righthand accomplishments
if you have a if you have a car without an exhaust
But let's get it. Let's just put aside
The question of is the you know production and making new cars. Whatever yeah people always make new cars, okay?
Forget about that
Even if producing the electricity now from a freaking coal plant is
Just as polluting as putting gasoline in your car
first of all gas you can as solar and wind
And all these renewable energies that don't give off any pollutants become more you know cost-effective as they do every year
You have the option to plug that shit into your car. Yeah, you plug that in from the outlet to your car
Okay, coal gasoline
You can't do that dude
And if you think that in a hundred years risk of me doing gas if you think that's just an option forever get fucking real
tears
Ten year give it ten. I give it ten years too, but people like oh
It's just as polluting to make a lecture card, and I was always talking about oh
It's inevitable electric cars nobody's done. It. Nobody stepped up to the fucking plate and risk their ass to do it until he did
he's the guy who did it and
Seriously when electric cars are fucking everywhere. He's going to be the guy who did it
I mean, I know you really took a huge risk. What is all his money right? Yeah?
I'm just locally invested in it, and it didn't go well in the beginning. Everybody said was going to fail
the
Regulators were against him that they still don't let him have dealerships he sells
Direct that model doesn't exist almost in car manufacturing
You have to go the website and buy it you have to wait like six months to get in a car
That's how good of a product and how good people want
You know it's insane that the odds were stacked against the guy and Beyond that
And also just for the record the electric vehicle has an effective 100 miles per gallon
right now
So fuck off haters
Don't ever say that to me again. Don't ever talk to me or my hair again
Mm-Hmm. It's don't talk to me on my elan don't ever talk to deer might you on again and
And then furthermore he has his company solarcity which just got absorbed into Tesla
It's one company now, but the guy let me show you this shit. I mean, Tesla. We're we're in both company
He's our Company's his so yeah
But they I don't know why they absorbed it own to tell I think what happened was his cousin or someone had
Ok was a co-founder of of Solar City, and he just absorbed it
Ok look at this look at this house you want to know what the fuck's going on with the future
Look at this house look ordinary deal these shingles here art oh my God
Click here if it's a doctor's gotta know these these roofing that you see here is solar panels you guys
that's solar out that's
Powering the house charging the car
completely off the grid
Hmm
ok and
his goal with this is to make it better looking more adorable Durable and
cheaper and she and eventually cheaper so that it's like people don't even have the choice and
It looks amazing
Do you see this guy?
He's fucking changing the world like people always talk about it like it's inevitable this guy's
How does one guy do all this it's crazy. He's amazing. He's he's he's like. Uh he they do
Yeah, this is where he's these once and a hundred
When a thousand year a guy who caught the rolls around and just you know beats and fucking beat the shit out of the earth
You know I?
Have so much every. I don't know I man I have a friend. Who's like. I don't like him. I don't trust him
I'm like a baby
And one of our best friends I get so triggered fun, and you got no function
There's no basis to the head it. Just don't you just hate him so even put so here's his beef with him
He's working on this other project
Called um the boring company. He says again. This is Elon. He sees a huge problem
traffic in Los Angeles
Traffic as you know if you don't live in Los Angeles
Traffic is impossible if you have never been here. It's hard to believe
How bad it is yeah? I thought coming from tel Aviv. I thought we've had
Like horrible traffic, it's a joy oh my God
It's nothing compared to here. Give me an idea to write to drive like 20 miles. It takes like an hour
during the Day do
We sometimes just consider not going places because of traffic like it's one of the it's how you make decisions here
Yeah, exactly, and it's funny because if you go somewhere like past eleven when the traffic is gone
It'll take you 15 minutes to get somewhere where it will actually take you an hour or more during at it?
So he's like, okay traffic. What's up with traffic, right?
So the dude is drilling fucking tunnels under the freeway
to
Transport like a superhighway for cars, so it took your car drops under and a highway
And it goes on like a conveyor belt, and it blasts you at higher you yeah?
There's really everybody you can get Michelle interesting to see
boring companies
Video and it blasts you at high speed here at watch this video. This is great
Those tunnel tunnels look pretty wild yeah, it's pretty loud. It's actually not what I expected. Yeah, it works
So there's basically platforms you drive on to and it lowers you underground
and
It just blunt and then here you go. There's like Super highways underground
that bypass the traffic and the roads and
It launches you out like 100-plus miles per hour
And then it lets you up
So the car is not even note. Yeah the car doesn't run
It's on a plug you're not even putting mileage on your car, right? Oh, it goes 200 km/h. They aren't as fast
It's funny the future is so not what people imagine in some ways in some flying cars because when you look at like the future
Yeah, you imagine stuff in the air. Yeah, don't actually imagine digging under an earth. Yeah
So my favorite part about all of this is that he called it the boring company. Yeah, and so Jeannie is so good
um
Anyway, it's just an idea obviously he did start drilling
He look people are saying oh, it's not happening lowell people always said that to elon you think you oughta listen you haters
Googas Ition boring company drill, you already built a fucking one-of-a-kind well
Even if it doesn't happen at least the guys trying. Tell me it's not happening look at these pictures
Try to tell me this shit's not happening
Look at this fucking drill thing that I miss epic here
This is how it works. It's like this crazy stated our drill
wow, it's not happening look at them lowering the drill into a pan and
Look at this
It's not happening. They says it's not happening. They says get real
if
Elon Wills it
Let it happen. Why anyway our friend was like. Oh, I don't like this because it's like class warfare all the rich people get a
Superhighway and
All the poor people have to be on the freeway. I'm like dude stop
That still means less people on the freeway first of all less traffic on the freeway
And oh my God toll roads already fucking exist dude. Yeah
stop
anyway
I'm going to be honest we got a tesla recently-released
Thing I said was I'm not into having nice cars. I never was we had a prius that was all I ever wanted but
It's more about just like fucking supporting this this movement that I love about going
Eco-friendly, it's sick. I mean I like the car the cars dope
I really like it, but it's like there's no exhaust pipes on the car
You plug it in in your garage you wake up every morning with a full tank of gas
It's cool, man, I
Like it. Why do you like to tesla? I actually really like it. It's funny
I thought that it was like so unnecessary because we had the prius and right like my doing in this and
I thought it. It's just going to be another car, but it's actually really cool, and I'm not obviously this is not like I paid
Anything I'll say, I'm sorry
Okay
But it is really cool
They make some new stuff that I never thought of before like the gas and brake and we'll add on it so much
I don't know if you want to explain it so they have what's called um
One Pedal
Driving this is actually one of my favorite features yeah mine, too, so unexpected that I would love it
That first it's really awkward and weird, so the gas pedal when you take your foot off the gas it breaks
Yeah, actually it breaks. You still have the brake too
So yeah sometimes you need to like slow down fast, and you know whatever you have a brake
But it's pretty intense when you take your foot off the gas so 90% of the time
I don't even need the brake yeah, and it's used to regenerate energy for the battery too, and also I've just notice that
It's so much more immediate when you're braking or slowing down that it feels a lot safer
I think so when I'm when I drive our prius now, and I take my foot off the gas
And it's almost like it you go
Yeah gliding at the same speed on my foot because if you need to react immediately there's a few sec's yes. Yeah
It's crazy
And then you know you know yvonne's not satisfied just to make an electric car
The self-driving is like let's Sprinkle that shit in there too, and it works amazingly all right this morning
I was having a little breakfast in the car you put on auto drive in the traffic and like
I'm good, dude. I eat my my breakfast my coffee I've got an auto drive
It's sick it feels safe because the car so responsive. I like it a lot, but more than that
I just like supporting the the movement
It's obviously an expensive car. I think when the model 3 comes out which is the
it's like
More than half the price of that one
Then I'm good. I can't wait for the solar roofs to become like the mainstream
They're available
But now, it's probably expensive. Yeah, it's expensive as fuck but
You know he's out there. He's shaking his dick, but it needs welding
Almost everyone had well not everyone, but a lot of them the majority of the houses have
Solar heater for the water
So when you shower, and you take a hot water
You know a hot shower you turn on the I mean if it's if it's in the summer
You don't need to turn it on because it's always on the sun, and I've always loved it like it's just such a simple
Great thing it's so weird. I mean you have hot water
It's after being in israel for five years. It's crazy to think that that's not everything in America
Yeah
And it's always been in I don't know why it's such a thing like you if you ever get a shot from above you'll see
That every roof has a solar panel around the old one and I read a report that it cuts down on like
Six or eight percent of energy consumption from the country's power grid that's significant
Yeah an la that would work me anyway. We're getting there. It's inevitable
I see more more solar power every day when I'm coming to la so he lon I
Got your back dude. I
got your dick I
Don't know if he wants that, but he does scare me and this gets into the point
I wanted to talk about neal I'm starting to freak me the fuck out because he's talking about Ai
He's been in the news a lot talking about the dangers of artificial intelligence
saying that it poses a
greater threat than North Korea
Is the greatest existential crisis? We've ever faced as a species that we need to start regulating it like
Drugs and weapons and stuff like that. He said something like if you're not worried about Ai you should be right?
It's like oh shit. I wasn't worried about it until you said it
I know I mean
But it's like here's a guy who I trust and mayer talked about it like that kind of does spook me a little bit
so just to give you a little background that he owns a company called open AI and
they're basically just testing the limits of how far can they take AI and
So the international is a dota tournament that took place recently the best dota players in the world
So dota is like a competitive game where?
two teams of players fight each other on an
Arena of
some sort and it's a very high level skill based game with a lot of Chaos a lot is happening a lot of data to
Understand and crunch kind of like starcraft right yeah like starcraft. It's like chess real-time chess
and
So they are like well, this is a good
This is a good platform to to test this bots to test this AI because if it can excel at this and be humans then
That's a good place to start right. It's like a
Real-time chess game I've seen people say it's more difficult than chess
Well, it's more complex. I
Think from a from a computer standpoint definitely because there's way more unknown. Just moving partners up. Yeah, you know
So basically they made this bot that could play
they could play dota 1V1 and they brought it to the biggest to turn right in the world called the international and
here's one of the best players in the world his name's dandy, and he's playing one verse one verse this bar and
This bot went like 10 enou against everybody, but this is one of the best players in the world
And he's getting fucking cream like he doesn't have a single chance against this bod
Russia's
He's on the right the bots on the left
Excited its infancy I
Can really not intervene at all I give up giving up yeah, I can steer like
Recognizable team I've seen it quite a lot this week and okay
Value away, this was at the end of a long one
we won battle that was the second round against him and he
getting creamed is he a the bot is on another level and this is one of the best players in the world and obviously the
bot has the ability to make decisions immediately doesn't have to think about anything doesn't have to think about taking a
Healing or doing an attack or calculating range, but that's why it's so terrifying yeah, all immediate it's yeah
The bot doesn't need time to think when you give my humans tasks, and it learns to do it it there
They're so vastly like if you have a true Ai they're going to look at us like
Frigate then we have the intellect of a mouse you
know
everything immediately makes sense to them they calculate and
Rationalize any problem immediately and it's and our brains are just pathetic. I mean ultimately so the danger is there I?
Can see that for sure if it if a machine somehow gets past a moral barrier that's coded into itself
Who knows what decisions?
It's going to optimize if if humanity or life on Earth becomes part of its optimization code
Yeah for whatever purpose. It sees who fucking knows you know
Elin says he's afraid that humans will become second-class citizens to robots
It's essentially like a dystopian Matrix more stored Susan - yeah
It sector exactly was world Susan so here's the engineer of that bot
basically explaining
What happened comprehend this these are prone planes? He's a human brain
Someone is telling me this variable has failed so many times
It's actually better than professional dota player
it's putting four really lifetimes of experience and
It's quite so many games of dota as exploring many different strategies learn to be learn to exploit other people debate
and it's just played far more into the strategy as any human as
So turns out worried about star deeply
How they just played dota 24 hours a day
Don't need us if you can do in the second time so I find that explanation was actually really interesting or fascinating should I say?
fascinating because
It's like this bot can just play dota
lifetimes in
The Span of like a year even that's right
How long I think they were doing it for for well a year or less?
Okay in a year they can play a hundred lifetimes of straight dota
You know and as an amount of experience that no human could ever achieve no amount of date. You know
It's it's pretty interesting stuff
They say is that next year during the next international
They're going to try to make a full five-man team to compete against the best team in the world
That's going to be something to watch. Yeah, you know they're going to win the bottom to win, right?
else so then
Zuckerberg Mark Zuckerberg my favorite person who represents my favorite company cancer book
started talking shit on my boy Elon and I'm like what does
Zuckerberg, I don't like zuckerberg. I don't like his company. I don't like a stupid smarmy face, and I don't like
other things about him
He says about Elon
Basically our main reason is freebooting on Facebook
Right among their among many others is our own device. That's just like the
It's the best example of how they do business on Facebook. I think so the fact they let that
Go, and they reward people who do it and pay them is
Really representative, but they're one of the most unscrupulous
Disgusting companies. I think the way they farm data
They don't they've done experiments on people trying to manipulate their mood
Try to sell them products they'll show them post that they know will make them sad so they can sell them Kleenex or whatever
for prozac or
Ice cream or ice cream?
So then mark Zuckerberg starts getting butthurt at Elon and he says
He says that elon is being irresponsible and ridiculous. He said this publicly in a live stream about elon
he called it fear-mongering and
Elon
later Responds I've spoken to Zuckerberg about it and his
Understand me understanding on the topic is limited. Oh, it's fucking that's like that. I'm gonna be over
That's like an aI you talking about us right. This is uh not static
That's a bottle
And unlimited ending is limited and to be fair you run Facebook dude. What the fuck do you do except mine my data. I?
put a dick pic on Facebook so zuckerberg can mine it and
so
Apparently and also ironically zuckerberg the one is like. Oh this guy's fear-mongering fuck this guy
We spoke about a couple weeks ago
Facebook is the one who created these chat bots right and they vented their own language
Yeah to start communicating with each other and broke the protocol that was designed for them and had to be shut off
Yeah, and he's the one being like oh you fear-mongering
he's the one developing Skynet in his basement and
So there's he actually the beef goes even deeper, and I love this whole story. It's great
It's a it's a classic story of good versus Evil in my mind
So space x forget about YouTube john oh my God
This is on a whole nother level
Spacex was
Elon Space Company, well it was
responsible for launching one of their internet beaming
satellites on the Falcon 9 rocket that blew up upon launch was one of their failed launches
And that was Facebook's satellite that was going to go fly over Africa and give everybody free access to the internet
known as Facebook's free basics and
so that satellite got blown up when the Falcon 9
failed to launch and exploded um
Marx said about that as I'm here in Africa and
My ivory tower in my palace in Africa
and I have an African beautiful woman fanning me with a palm leaf and
Feeding me grapes like Jabba the alright again on I'm easily disappointed to hear that Spacex launch failure destroyed our satellite
They would have provided connectivity to so many entrepreneurs and everyone else across the continent
Is that him so I'll true a sick and amazing that Facebook was going to launch a satellite over Africa to give them free internet
Yeah
but wait
It was actually just some fucking scheme
Yeah, those are the scheme
This is what a Scheme was it sounds like this can
Would you seriously trust Facebook the altruistic company to be an internet free internet to engine?
It's so shady that India when they launched it over India banned it
They banned anyone from accessing it because they called it essentially digital
Colonialism it was a data mining scheme disguised as humanitarian aid
with bloated for targeted companies apps and get this it was like you just
Connect to it and then you can use the internet you have to use it using only a Facebook app
of course and then the the data in India was that apparently
Almost nobody was connecting to it for the first time with the internet
90% of people are using we're just out of data and use it as access Facebook
Fucking asshole. I'm going to save the world. I'm here in Africa. I was going to save this
this flea-Ridden country
Thank you. I will take another creep shit
Fuckin
Whatever they caught you know I love that Indian bandit
They banned his ass they know what's up and he has been doing good lately actually I'm proud of India lately
They also passed a bunch of legislation legislation
Committing to going solar and yeah, they're very tough they're very
They speak a lot about the global warming. It's good. Well. They're one of the biggest you know
Effects telling by it you know not affect that yeah, but they're burning a lot of coal
But they're developing country
It's hard anyway that's yeah, that's a whole different thing, but anyway
I just love that that Marx trying to make it seem like this guy
Just kill all the internet for Africa
so
yeah, that's about it and yesterday you had a little heart attack right when when your phone beeped and
You got a Twitter notification. Oh, God?
This was so fun
So I'm on my phone last night preparing for this podcast today and on Twitter
It says Elon musk followed you back
and
This wasn't no fake shit like it's it was verified Elon musk at Elon musk follow you back
And I was like either way, she was nothing like yo stop
open Twitter and
Man, I don't know if I got goofed if it was a bug if he had like accidentally followed me then unfollowed me
broke my heart man
He didn't follow basically, so you think that you know. I'm just saying for the people listening no
He's not so currently follow me
Yeah, what do you think happened because I'm a hundred percent sure I saw Hila I must follow you back
but if you're sure that it said
They followed you back it said that so I think maybe he follow you by mistake
And then unfollowed because you didn't know like it clicks on a stake somehow oh
Man is person
well
He's pretty much my probably my number one
Most is our guest
The guy is deep into everything I care about he's at the heart of it and let me tell you this about you on keys
fascinating fascinating
Thank you, Dim
Anyway, that's pretty much what I have for today
I hope you guys enjoyed that now it is time to bring in the news with Dan
Let's take a short break and then we'll just hop on to the news with dan to wrap up the show
So we'd be back in a quick two minutes my friends
Stay tuned Welcome back everybody to the H3 podcast
weekly top of the week our
New episode I hope you guys are enjoying it
We're back with the news with Dan dan. Why don't you take us off?
People who probably heard but over the last 10 years or so there's been a lot of research into using Magic mushrooms in
Therapy you know it apparently has been proven that it can be effective at treating people with PTSd and Depression
and a multitude of other conditions and everything and
researchers have just
Discovered this breakthrough where they can essentially synthesize the enzyme that makes you trip the fuck out when you're taking mushrooms
So now it can be kind of put into medicine and done
And you know a more clinical way than eating nasty dirt mushrooms
So you don't you don't need to eat cow pies anymore cow pies yeah, right?
But it will trip you out the same if you take the medicine
That's what they're saying
Essentially, this is the this is the active ingredient
So to speak in those cow pies or mushrooms that grow on cow pies that uh?
that you know completely makes you trip the fuck out and
so
Yeah, basically you know a lot of very reputable
Research institutes have said that this legitimately is one of the best methods that they've ever seen
When used in a clinical environment, they're not saying everybody should take mushrooms behind
You know if somebody you know suffering depression or has severe pTSd
In the right environment with the therapists there with you kind of babysitting your trip
you can kind of
Talk through it and by the time you come out of the experience. You're actually feeling much better
and they they say in the article, I think they said
They found it to be effective up to about six months well
Right so you guys get a great one every six months or something like that, and you're good
Yep, you just go in and drip all
Tri-Annual, I mean answer the doctor
I've heard that before I've heard they also do medical tests with MDMa without sweating good. I'd like
if it's ready to sign up sign up for that doctor I
Got a couple cow pies for you
It's really interesting you know it's cool to see these drugs that have been previously
Such strong stigma around
An actual medical professional being like what there's actually something we can do with this
Especially if you live in the controlled yeah environment that by the way let me stress
This this isn't saying go out and take these drugs is going to make you feel there that is not
it's not you have to do it in a controlled environment with the professional that being said if you go out to the forest and
Look for giant cow dumps you may get lucky all right cool great interesting story. What's up next?
When we have up here next we've got North Korea
Right so you have to be living under a rock to not have heard of this
But you know this this was a big deal in the last week and felt like something. We should probably touch on
you know
tensions with North Yeah in this kind of rhetoric of Lego
We're going to bomb you has been going on forever right like it's at the point where everybody just kind of rolls their eyes like
Sure the difference this time
is
apparently North Korea has
miniaturized their nuclear weapon
Small enough that in theory they could put this on a missile and hit the continental united States
Especially relevant for us here because they you know what caught my eye is they keep mentioning. You know Los Angeles. That's that's in range
So this feels a little different this time because of that they backed off wom
to threaten so an
Tensions have stabilized there. They're no longer threatening to bomb guam dangle for guam at respect
it's easy to see that like oh nothing was ever going to happen but
Again every time prior to this we could say oh nothing's going to happen because nothing can happen now it can happen now
They they have the technology to nuke us fuck it. I'm going back to Israel in there, just a identify left Israel to
beautiful Los Angeles
By the way when that was wrong
the fuck did Wom do
Good like battle we're Gonna long long big wom Sort of like what the fuck we do
Mom's like A u.s. Territory. They can't even vote. They're basically just slaves to America. Yes, I'm gonna bomb
Well my guys when you're using the wall Street Journal' prince inside
Let me know someone point going like that out Hawk. Oh
That's right. You guys portal ministry there I
Just quickly get off that story right away. I'm kidding. What else did you have anything else Dad?
uh no just that I don't want to get new I guess I mean that's the fair point death by Nuke is kind of
May not be the worst way to go. I mean you'll get anywhere you won't get over here if you're oh
My God these ads
Um yeah it really depends where you are
But I I'd look I mean getting vaporized quick-and-dirty, right?
Anyway, what else we got?
alright, and then this one I
want to say made me happy because that's kind of dark, but
the game Hunter trampled to death by
elephant in
Nam
Media no media that's a country that I've heard of that's what I decided ignorant. Good luck
I shouldn't shoot him like relish in the fact that I've never heard of this country
This place on Earth nom nom, Nom. I know Nam Bia. Is that nomming. I'm a certain
Ambiance what I thought it says but I mean now that I'm looking at it alright
There's a place out there called Nam Joo 90s. Don't ever forget it
So yeah this guy from Argentina went hunting elephants because that's still a thing people do apparently oh
Yeah, and uh you know
I'm not relishing in his death necessarily, but you gotta love the irony right I mean and
People that go out and do big-game hunting I'm relishing in it, and how give a guy a just film shit
No looks like the elephant fucked him up look we all go out for that because usually they're like from Far away
And they're not even doing anything
it's just they just pay someone to hunt for them, and then they take a picture with the dead anymore like they did something that
Yeah, I mean that may have been the case here, but they just fucked up
But it's when you're on this big-game hunt right the whole point is like miiverse to animal
That's the whole point and how how long side it is that game?
How often does the human lose well guess what boys?
today the Human Loss
Human law yeah, it's under even if you're like
It's an underdog story
Everybody loves an underdog story fuck that guy he went out there shaking his dick trying to get his his fuckin nut off
Feel like a big man killing a beautiful
immaculate
Majestic elephant I
Really don't get these people really don't get it. Yeah
I did the whole thing is so weird they paid thousands of dollars
And then the whole thing is it uptake they go they meet these people or locals and the locals tell them exactly
Where the animals going to be? It's all organized them
Yeah, you you spend here the animal will be there and that you just click this thing and then you have a picture, right?
$20,000 qui we tranquilized that animal he subdued
He all a on the ground all you have to do is go to deliver the final blow
I masturbate with his blood yes. We do love that does well
Can't even argue that
It's the thrill of you know stalking through the brush, and you know
Tracking this animal for miles on end and taking it down or whatever
I mean that's so fucked up, but you can make an argument that that's like a you know
Thrilling experience or something but this is it I mean, it's just handed to you on a silver platter just
Hey like like you said you just pull the trigger just hey you get to kill this thing. I'm not gonna
I'm not denouncing all hunting like some is fine
I'm talking specifically about this guy
So it's this rich people who pay like twenty thousand dollars to go shoot some really exotic
I have like like announcement a like auction off the rights to kill one
exotic government and
the money goes to conservation
quote-unquote which means the local governments back pocket
where you know and
Elephants are essentially non-human intelligent life
Elephants are one of the most intelligent creatures on Earth they recognize those Amir's they have complex language and culture you
Know it's an argument in my opinion an elephant killing Alvin is kind of murder same with like a dolphin
quote same with like a fucking gorilla I
Mean it's kind that you're murdering a nonhuman creature. I know there's not many non-human creatures in my opinion who are
Sentient on an ear level as us, but elephants are one of them certainly
absolutely
But you know there's invasive. There's overpopulation. There's deer and shed that's perfectly acceptable to go hunt
Yeah, but this shit is weird
Anyway, you got fucking killed. What happened?
Trampled so he took a shot
He took a shot and he fucking missed and elephant took him out
pretty much
Said the hunter identified as a 48 year old Jose Mandalas was killed on Saturday afternoon in a private wildlife area
43 Miles Northwest of a small town and calc feld
the dude worked for an oil company class act
Wow, if I got charged well, they all died with another Argentinian and three Nam beings
Working and me me wait
Wait, whose work wait?
What clarified the that's how you say I guess I I don't I don't believe they all died was I was
Wildly so the elephant was like fuck this guy in particular
Yeah, and this is a this kind of things kind of to your point of how they're near sentient
elephants that are kind of in these areas that this goes on the ones that survive they
They hold grudges essentially and there's even been stories of them. You know essentially
attacking Villages in what kind of activity a pSeudo organized Manner where they'll you know they'll mess up and
charge you know in a wall of
Elephants, and you know mess without event and that's what humans would do right?
and it was kind of like the same in fjords with the Shamu and the killer whales the
few times the killer whales actually killed the
The trainers right because it's like fuck you lavery
Stop bossing me around and free me. Yeah, yeah mmm on some level they understand
I think yeah and killer whales are one of them too. Yeah, you know
Well, that's just my opinion folks and that we need like a slogan, and that's the way
It goes down
Well, that's our show. That's our Tuesday show
Hope you guys had fun. Let us know what you thought. We'd think we're gonna keep doing it every week
I like the balance here between
Having us doing our thing here and having a guest on Friday
It's a good balance to beat to be truthful with you my dream although. It's far off from now, is to do it every weekday
But that's a far. Oh that's that's far far far away that is a fascinating fascinating but for now. It's a to date
I like that balance for now
We should call this a bit fascinating show
This is the fascination hour. I found it really fascinating the fascination hour guys
Anyway, I hope you all had a good time hope you had a laugh. Happy Wednesday my dudes
See you on Friday for Jake Paul and the KTLA reporter looking forward to that
until then my friends
I shall be calling you with my thoughts and prayers and to everybody who has supported us graciously through Amazon
Twitch Prime
I will think of you the next time I make love.
Bye my friends.